let's quickly recap what we saw in the
previous video a complex number A plus
bi can be plotted in two ways first a
units to the right and B units up assume
that this length OB is our units and
this angle from the positive x-axis is
theta so the second way to represent
point P is R comma theta if you're
looking at this right triangle this
length is a this length is B this length
is our angle POA is Theta and this angle
is 90 degrees now let's just focus on
this triangle and nothing else let me
ask you a simple question
can you tell me the length of R in terms
of a and B come on you should be able to
answer this as this is a right triangle
we can use the Pythagorean theorem to
find our R squared will equal a squared
plus B squared the square of the
hypotenuse is equal to the sum of the
squares of the other two sides taking
the square root on both sides we get the
value of R as root of a squared plus B
squared this is nothing but the modulus
of the complex number said we had
covered this in one of our videos if the
complex number Z is equal to a plus bi
then the modulus of this complex number
set is the square root of a squared plus
B squared it's also known as the
absolute value of the complex number
what is Theta then it's called the
argument of Z which can also be written
like this now that we know how to
represent R in terms of a and B can you
try and derive theta in terms of a and B
let me give you a hint
use trigonometric identities in this
triangle do you remember the code we
used for the three basic functions in
trigonometry
yes it's sohcahtoa sine is opposite over
hypotenuse cos is adjacent over
hypotenuse and tan is opposite over
adjacent so sine theta can be written as
B over R we get the value of B as R sine
theta cos theta can be written as a over
R which tells us that a is R cos theta
now we have a and B in terms of R and
theta
but we still don't have theta in terms
of a and B but are these two enough to
give us that yes all we need to do is
divide B by a R gets cancelled and we
get B over a as sine theta over cos
theta and what's sine over cos its tan
tan theta will equal B over a hence
theta will equal tan inverse of B over a
that's theta in terms of a and B with
this we have successfully represented R
and theta in terms of a and B so if we
have the real and imaginary part of the
complex number we can represent it in
the polar form as well in the process of
doing this we've also derived a couple
of other relations a is R cos theta and
B is R sine theta so the complex number
A plus B I can also be written as R cos
theta plus R sine theta times I as R is
common to both the terms we can write it
as R times cos theta plus I sine theta
this is the polar form of the complex
number R is the modulus of Z and theta
is the argument of Z so if we are given
a and B we can get the polar coordinates
R and theta and if we are given the
polar coordinates we can get the values
of real and imaginary parts why do we
need the polar form we all
use this concept in locating a point V
specified direction along with the
distance from a central point for
instance while marking places on a map
we say that a particular city is 200
kilometers northeast so R is 200 and
theta is 45 degrees I also want to show
you a beautiful way to have a polar
representation graph this is how you can
imagine it this is a one unit radius
circle this is the two units radius
circle and so on and these are angles
marked at intervals of 15 degrees so if
R is 3 units and theta is 45 degrees the
point will lie here if R is 2 units and
theta is 135 degrees the point will lie
here if R is 4 units and theta is 315
degrees the point will lie here you may
not see this diagram in the textbooks
but it's a really good way to understand
the polar representation the next video
will cover examples of expressing
complex numbers using the polar
representation
[Music]